blade smith's congratulations you've
made it to the final round of this
competition now we're sending you back
to your home for just to recreate an
iconic weapon from history
the war galac
originating in the philippines during
the 16th century the war galact featured
a straight double-edged blade with no
tip due to the spanish occupation at the
time filipinos were outlawed from having
pointed swords and the blade was often
used for vegetation and chopping wood
however by the philippine revolution in
1896 filipinos adapted to the tipless
weapon and it became a weapon of war it
was so effective in battle and inspired
later variations of the weapons such as
the british military's army galac in the
early 1950s
good luck blade smiths we'll see you in
five days
my name is matt wagner i run an auto
body restoration shop and i work with
metal every day i started watching
forges and fire and one day i was like
you know what i think i can do that i'm
ready to crank this baby up
i'm anxious because i have never made a
sword this long
i want to win this competition because
i've always thought i was meant to do
something better
today is our make or break it point my
main concern is quenching the blade
because it could create massive warping
this is the big moment
it's freaking straight
so now that i'm quenched i'd like to
take a couple whacks at a piece of wood
just to see what's gonna happen
[Music]
i've shattered my blade into three
pieces
this is an epic failure
i'm running out of time
i'm gonna have to start over
i might not finish this thing
my plan is to use a piece of leaf spring
and get a complete sword forged out in
one day
i'm working on a deadly timeline and i
am just busting my
[Music]
i got to get my crunch done by the end
of day four because
i don't know if i have a good blade yet
i may have to build another one tomorrow
you never know it's cool pretty quick
i'm running out of time
if this blade doesn't harden with this
quench i'm really screwed
i got my fingers crossed
we've got a hard blade
i am super happy
looks like i'm gonna have something for
the big show
[Music]
my name is brian schmidt i believe my
great grandfather was a blacksmith so
when i saw forged and fire i wanted to
try and make my own plates and just
create memories with my family
i think i have a pretty good chance of
winning the basic shape of my blade is
in there now this is going to be the
orgolic the blade's looking really nice
got the handle set up for a lot of work
today
the handle's made out of maple it's also
the part of the knife where i'm
customizing it for myself a little bit
yeah not so bad i think they turned out
pretty nice i sharpened my blade three
times
the thing's razor sharp
all right
feels good
now i want to go test the blade and my
son is joining me
ready all right here we go
awesome
that thing slices right through it feels
good in my hand so i think it's gonna do
well
all right very deadly
bladesmiths to see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do we'll take
your sword and deliver hacks and slashes
on this big carcass
brian you're up first you ready for this
absolutely
depending on where you hit that blade
you know it can always snap apart
bladesmiths but unfortunately i'm still
recovering from an injury so
anthony one of my senior instructors of
marquette kali will be the butcher to
your pork chop
all right brian let's talk about your
blade first up your edge is razor sharp
it lacerated easily through bones
through the spine the one issue here is
that you have a very blocky handle aside
from that it will kill good job thanks
matt ready to chop i've been ready let's
do this
[Music]
okay matt it's balance and weight is
very forward for a chopper but your edge
is sharp enough to lacerate into the
carcass it did chop the spine it did
chop bone
this
will kill
thank you
gentlemen this is a strength test to
test the strength and durability of your
edge i'm going to chop into these huge
logs 10 times remember this test is all
about what happens to your weapons and
not what happens to the logs brian
you're up first you ready i think so
yeah
all right
[Music]
[Music]
made it
well brian your edge held up perfectly
there's no bending no warping just still
razor sharp all the way down
man
it was fun to swing well done thank you
matt you're up you ready give it a try
all right
[Music]
ah
well matt there's so much forward weight
that it actually
bent that way
on the plus side
your edge up beautifully i mean there's
no problems with that edge at all it's
still very sharp
but this s-bend in it
it's significant
bladesmiths you both brought in some
pretty extraordinary historic weapons
but in this arena of competition there
can only be one forged and fire champion
brian
congratulations you are the new fortune
fire champion
matt unfortunately your blade did not
make the cut
matt your blade is impressive we saw
that it could kill but unfortunately in
the strength test it took a significant
bend and it's for that reason we have to
let you go
i understand
matt please surrender your glock
even with losing at the end of the day i
don't feel like i really lost because i
went way further than i ever expected
i don't know enough about it yet that i
can make that perfect blade so
you know i'll keep learning
brian you are the new forged and fire
champion and that comes with a check for
ten thousand dollars good job thank you
guys thank you
please present your weapon to the judges
it feels great to be forged the fire
champ i can't believe i won it's awesome
i would say if somebody wants to start
learning how to make a knife start out
watching force and fire you started
episode one binge watch
you